suite justement faire le point sur place
avec notre reporter d'avis de khalifa
david est ce que vous m'entendez alors
vous étiez en fin de cortège tout à
l'heure dans une ambiance plutôt bon
enfant et puis là aussi ça a un peu
dégénéré où en est la situation de votre
côté david
ça a dégénéré c'est le mot olivier une
situation extrêmement tendue ici est
toujours près de la porte des lilas
finalement puisque le cortège a été
statique du début à la fin ils ont dû
même ont retiré puisqu'il ya eu
plusieurs projectiles des manifestants
envers les forces de l'ordre les forces
de l'ordre ont répondu par des gaz
lacrymogènes
vous le voyez derrière moi des incendies
de panneaux publicitaires les pompiers
ont été obligés d'intervenir des
incendies également de poubelles mais
cette situation était vraiment très
tendues pour moi il était impossible de
pouvoir reporter ce qui se passait sur
le terrain puisque des gaz lacrymogènes
ont été tirés en abondance vers nous il
était impossible de respirer j'ai donc
dû mettre le matériel de protection
et c'est assez c'est assez aberrant de
devoir à de voir ces images est
finalement puisque c'est ce mouvement se
veut se veut pacifique est la plupart
des manifestants en tout cas étaient
venus manifester pacifiquement ici pour
pour protester contre ce projet de loi
sécurité globale et c'est vrai que d'un
coup ça a dégénéré encore une fois les
forces de l'ordre sont intervenues à
plusieurs reprises le préfet dit des
allemands avaient prévenu qu'ils ne
voulaient pas de scénario similaire à la
semaine dernière et finalement on en
revient encore une fois à des heurts
entre manifestants et policiers encore
une fois à cette méthode cette stratégie
d'aidé et idéalement des tac tranche des
manifestants eh bien c'est ce qui à ses
skis temps finalement un peu le cortège
et cette mobilisation
l'objectif est toujours le même pour ces
un millier de manifestants dans la rue
c'est le retrait pur et simple de ce
projet de la sécurité globale
ils sont venus également un pour leurs
acquis sociaux manifester contre le
chômage on est manifesté contre le
licenciement abusif et puis hein
et bien finalement on en revient aussi
au gilet jaune puisque la plupart des
dirigeants qui sont dans le cortège
m'ont dit que voilà qu'ils avaient
l'impression de revenir au samedi à 2018
puisque c'est elle et les mêmes
circonstances pour pour ces manifestants
et finalement il y aura un mouvement de
foule assez impressionnant ici c'est
vraiment vraiment triste de voir à quel
point une manifestation à cette
manifestation a pu générer puisque vous
disiez tout à l'heure
olivier est l'ambiance était très
festive beaucoup de camions beaucoup de
musique et le problème est que la des
familles étaient également présentes au
sol du corset des enfants ont reçu des
gaz lacrymogènes beaucoup de blessés
aussi à des membres et dont un blessé
grave
un médecin a vu intervenir en urgence
vous l'aurez compris la situation est
extrêmement tendue et à la mobilisation
la manifestation ne pourra pas aller à
son terme en tout cas pour le moment il
est très très compliqué de pouvoir dire
que le cortège maroc pointe pour se
rendre à la place de la république
là où la manifestation doit de se finir
lieu de dispersion de cette
manifestation contre le projet de loi de
sécurité globale merci beaucoup
david pour toutes les précisions vous
retrouve bien entendu tout au long de
cette édition spéciale